à
[Musique]
pendant que vous tourniez le clip de
votre tube cyril on a décidé de mettre
la chanson à fond dans la chanson dans
l'ascenseur de h2o beaucoup trop fort en
goût du non-stop pendant cinq heures
impossible de l'arrêter en début de
journée regarder pour au tiff
c'est vrai on se rattache de son
mais comme n'importe quel morceau plus
les heures passent plus les visages se
sert je vois que leur légende
l'or continue de tourner au bout d'un
moment tout le monde et pour l'espagne
olly moss pas chez nous qu'on est comme
la musique était à son non-stop
tout le monde se renvoie l'ascenseur
parce que même quand il a l'art et les
gens entend de la musique
vous allez voir tout le monde s'installe
matinée à se renvoyer la ferveur
[Applaudissements]
on a vu notre ami nourdine qui était au
bout du rouleau à 13h quand même on l'a
laissé pendant sept heures dans la fosse
aux serpents à bloc beau jeu dont celle
d'orange toi je t'ai pas vu l'enjeu des
tartes on l'a fait quelques fois j'étais
obligé de le faire quand même une une
dernière fois on a prétendu aux gens de
la société de comptes vais faire des
nouveaux badges et qu'il fallait de
reconnaissance faciale pour imprimer ce
nouveau badge
regardez le dispositif c'est un des plus
réussis qu'on ait fait ah oui les bonnes
écran un objectif un clavier et sous le
clavier
bien sûr vous allez le voir la tarte à
partir de là tout s'enchaîne très vite
v
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]